dans les familles musulmanes il y a une
une hiérarchie qui est très imposée dans
les quartiers il y a une hiérarchie très
imposé c'est pour ça que les filles
hésitent maintenant à sortir sans un
voile sur la tête c'est pour ça que il y
a constamment les pressions qui sont
fait sur eux c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
une
une une marche où tous les deux nous
marcherions main dans la main euh serait
très compliqué à mettre en
place mais non non parce que parce que
ça irait à l'encontre de la tactique des
islamistes qui souhaitent justement je
le répète diviser les communautés mais
ne le don pas alors mais les G les gens
qui vont à ces manifestations c'est pas
des islamistes les gens qui c'est faut
pas mettre tout le monde dans le même
sac et les et oui il y a des femmes
c'est vrai qu'il y a des femmes qui sont
forcesé à mettre le voile mais il y a
des femmes qui sont très heureuses ma
mère porte le voile je peux vous dire
qu'il y a personne qui la force à rien
faire c'est plus elle qui force mon père
à enlever ses chaussures quand elle
rentre à la maison comends non mais
après batac on a tous marché pourquoi là
on n pas capable de tous marcher
ensemble mais moi c'est c'est moi c'est
le je suis peut-être naïf comme vous
mais c'est le rêve que j'ai la et qu'on
soit tous apaisé vous avez vu que les
manifestations en soutien au peuple
palestinien sont interdites est-ce que
vous comprenez cette décision Gill moi
pas du tout je trouve que c'est une
erreur grave alors attention dès qu'il y
a un cri pro Hamas dès qu'il y a une
band rôle là apologie du terrorisme on
sanctionne on s vit mais que les gens
qui soutiennent le peuple palestinen
tout en condamnant bien sûr les
monstrueux attentats en Israël que ces
gens ne puissent pas dire leur soutien
au peuple au civille de Gaza je trouve
que c'est une erreur parce que comment
vont-ils pouvoir manifester ce soutien
s'ils ne peuvent pas le faire dans une
manifestation encadré sécurisé avec des
forces de l'ordre autour moi je crains
qu'il le fasse ailleurs où ce sera pas
encadré donc pour moi je comprends le
gouvernement mais pour moi c'est une
mauvaise décision est-ce que vous
comprenez cette décision Daniel ah oui
tout à fait moi j'été vraiment choqué
hier parce qu'on a quand même entendu à
4 jours non non mais tu comprends cette
décision toi la décision de l'avoir oui
interdit bien sûr parce que j'ai été
choqué par ces images c'est incroyable
d'entendre tu comprends la décision
d'interdire les les manifestations bien
sûr bien sûr et j'étais complètement
choqué je voudrais le dire parce que en
Israël assassin à 4 jours de
décapitation de bébés en Israël et et et
laisser ces gens ces gens-là parce qu'on
dit les réseaux sociaux les réseaux
sociaux il y a de la merde tout le temps
il y a des gens qui sont cachés qui
disent de la merde tout là ce sont des
gens à visage découvert on est en plein
Paris il y a 4 jours il y a eu mais des
abominations vous les avez et je je je
trouve que c'est bien de de les de les
raconter parce que on s'en rend pas
compte c'est des mots donc c'est très
bien ce que vous avez fait l shuraki et
on a entendu sioniste terroristes Israël
assassin on est dans des revendications
c'est moi ça j'ai été choqué j'ai eu
honte j'ai eu honte de mon pays il y a
pas que ça il y a pas que ça pas que ça
il y en a qui viennent dans la paix et
il y en a qui prent le même discours que
moi qui veulent juste marché et qui qui
att à 4 jours de ce qui s'est passé je
suis
désolé
partout dit qu' y en a dans la rue il y
en a partout des imbéciles dans ce genre
de moment tu dis ça pour moi je pens
mais je il y en a de partout mais
interdire bah malheureusement c'est
pousser les gens à l'affront c'est
pousser les gens à la sens mais si on a
un raisonement comme ça on interdit plus
rien c'est interdiss quelqu'un qui crie
mort au Juif bien évidemment bien
évidemment qu'on interdit quelqu'un et
qu'on punisse quelqu'un qui dit mort aux
juif évidemment ça coûte de sources le
le feu ça ça brûle et l'eau ça mouille
mais je veux dire un moment où faut les
laisser aussi s'exprimer c'est pas un
gros mot que S et puis on a un
gouvernement on a un gouvernement qui
est quand même logiquement censé pouvoir
encadrer des manifestations pour qu'ell
se passe dans de bonnes conditions pour
que les messages passés soient des
messages de paix si un moment ce
gouvernement là n'est pas capable de
gérer ça c'est un vrai sujet aussi donc
vous vous comprenez pas la décision moi
moi je je je la comprends vu la
tristesse de notre gouvernement et son
niveau par contre dans d'autres
circonstances je pense que ça aurait été
une bonne chose parce que ça peut être
aussi un message de paix Guillaume toi
tu es pas d'accordi je la comprends pas
parce que je trouve qu'il y a des
raccourcis et des amalgames qui sont
faits qui sont dangereux en fait on
sous-entend que cette manifestation en
fait en faveur des civils palestiniens
on fait passer ces milliers de personnes
pour des personnes qui cautionnent le
terrorisme qui encouragent le terrorisme
et qui sont d'accord avec ce qui sont
passés non c'est trop facile voilà il
faut expliquer les choses ces
personnages je ne peux pas croire que
les milliers de personnes qui sont là
sont des terroristes ou encouragent ce
qui s'est passé et malheureusement
aujourd'hui bah on tombe dans des
raccourcis on tombe dans des amalgames
et on veut opposer les gens et en
interdisant ce genre de chos on va
encore diviser on va encore créer des
tensions et c'est pas la je suis désolé
on est tombé hier sur Karim zé qui
disait oui mais là pour moi c'est oui
mais c'est on défend la cause
palestinienne quelque part c'est
justifié ce qui s'est passé il y a qu
jour ah
excusez-moi est-ce que vous comprenez la
décision du gouvernement je la comprends
moi je doute pas de la sincérité
effectivement de certains qui veulent
manifester pour le peuple palestinien et
qui qui ne qu' faut évidemment la
dissociation entre le peuple palestinien
et le Hamas mais la question qui se pose
c'est qui organise ces manifestations
parmi les organisateurs il y a action
Palestine je suis allée sur le site moi
d'action Palestine parce que ça
m'intéresse de savoir sur le site il y a
marqué que c'était une organisation pour
saluer l'exploit de la résistance
palestinienne ce qui s'est passé hier
avec le ce qui s'est passé avec le Hamas
c'est la résistance palestinienne tuer
des femmes et des enfants c'est la
résistance palestinienne c'est ça aid
est la cause palestinienne donc moi s'il
y a une manifestation où on arrive mais
je mais je je crains qu'on narrive pas à
le faire on arrive à dissocier
effectivement et et une vraie
manifestation en disant c'est un soutien
avec le peuple sauf que là ça va être
évidemment infé par moi ce ce qu'on
aimerait voir c'est des manifestations à
soutien en Israël où il est des
personnes qui fassent les deux person
ex et vrai
que ce qui est dramatique aujourd'hui
c'est que
voilà je peux poser une question à RAM
Ramous est-ce que vous vous pensez au
voilà au fond de vous et tout ça est-ce
que vous pensez vraiment que en France
les musulmans sont d'accord pour avoir
deux états au fond vraiment un état
palestinen état
israélien ce mais vous non mais vous
bien sûr évidemment c'est ce que vous
dit dans votre vidé pourquoi cette
marche n pas-oi si moi je marche dans
une manifestation alors si je vais comme
celle que de Sarah Alimi si j'entends
Mor aux Arabes je gifle la personne qui
dit ça si je vais dans une manifestation
palestinienne j'entends mort au Juif je
le gifle ben comme c'est l'immense
majorité cette marche est donc possible
bien sûr que c'est possible non mais on
sait très bien que c'est toujours la
minorité qui sont les fauteurs de
trouble aussi don pas raison à la
barbarie au
teroris les mecs qui tiennent ses propos
ils savent même pas mettre la Palestine
et l'Israël sur la carte mec sont
totalementignorant pas sûr que les gens
de la France les mettre aussi hein je
vous le dis je je pense vraiment que là
ils ont dû vérifier parce que ça fait
plusieurs fois que je leur dis donc ils
ont dire au cas où on vous interroge on
va les voir mais je pense qu'il y a une
semaine il savait pas vous mooun vous
êtes vous êtes vous comprenez pas la
décision non je comprends pas bah en
fait je rejoins un petit peu Gilles et
et Guillaume c'est en fait je je
comprends qu'aujourd'hui il y a un souci
de gestion de de ce conflit maintenant
aujourd'hui enfin je pense qu'une une
marche pour la paix c'est ce serait
vraiment la
it des
annissent je veux dire la Palestine
autant queisraël subisse des violences
depuis des années aujourd'hui si les
propalestiniens ont envie de faire une
manifestation une manifestation pour
faire entendre leur voix je comprends en
revanche action
Palestine entende mort au
Juif évidment les gens qui disent ça
évidemment que ils ont pas leoit de de
manifester maintenant je trouve que
c'est contreproductif que d'interdire
parce que du coup les gens vont vouloir
créer des manifestations en dehors de
l'autorisation et de quelque chose de de
de structurer et donc c'est là qu'il va
y avoir des violences et on va donner
raison en fait à ces violencesan Michel
mer ouais moi je crois que c'est là on
est des beaux discours mais c'est de
l'angélisme total parce que pour moi les
manifestations c'est pas des
manifestation de paix c'est des
manifestations de colère c'est une sorte
de rapport de force qu'on va instaurer
dans la rue et je crois que
malheureusement on est arrivé à un tel
stade c'est que maintenant on est arrivé
dans une sorte de choisis ton camp et
d'affrontement maintenant c'est on est
plus du tout dans la recherche d'un il
faudra qu'il a un gagnant quelque part
je me dis ça maintenant les deux camps
s'affrontent jusqu'à ce qu'il y a un
gagnant je le sens comme ça j'écoute la
plartcoup personnes
parendne réseau j'entend discours de P
exter quand tu écoutes les gens qui sont
engagés émotionnellement dans un camp ou
dans un autre ils sont plus dans la
recherche d'un compromis dans la
recherche d'une paix l'action qui a été
menée en Palestine par le Rama c'était
pas pour essayer de se mettre autour de
la table cé pour engager
une guerre totale entre tous les pays
qui composent le
proch tu fais pas ça quand tu veux la
paix tu fais pas ça donc là maintenant
tout le monde a bien compris le message
dans cas ou dans un autre que maintenant
on en est plus au discussion maintenant
il va falloir que ça FA et il fa un
gagnant moi je comm
ça je comprends la décision de Monsieur
Darmanin et je la trouve totalement
responsable parce que lui il est à la
tête d'un ministère qui a les les
renseignements
et qui connaît donc la vraie ligne de
fracture qu'il y a dans ce pays il a les
vrais remontées sur les actes
d'antisémitisme il a les vrais remontées
sur les niveau de tension qui peut y
avoir ici ou là son rôle c'est tout
simplement de protéger la population et
pas de faire en sorte que les les les
communautés se montent les unes contre
contre les autres et je rejoins tout à
fait ce que vient de dire Jean-Michel
c'est que malheureusement ce constat là
on peut pas faire d'angélisme
aujourd'hui le constat c'est que
malheureusement on n'est pas en mesure
de faire cette fameuse marche qu'on
aimerait tous voir où tout le monde
serait ensemble derrière la paix ou
derrière une volonté de deux états euh
et il faut pas dire n'importe quoi je
lisais également sur les réseaux que la
France fait rien contre il y a un homme
politique fameux qui dit aujourd'hui que
la France ne fait rien pour une solution
à deux états il y a eu c'est qui c'est
qui Villepin Dominique de vilpin non non
c'est c'est c'est la France insoumise
qui qui qui qui en remis une louche mais
non je veux dire il y a eu il y a eu il
y a eu beaucoup d'actions européennes ou
françaises pour essayer de faire en
sorte que euh il y a il y a une solution
à à deux États mais ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que ce que votre message il
est formidable ce soir et votre message
il est extrêmement puissant à l'un et à
l'autre et à mon avis c'est bien plus
porteur que malheureusement des
rassemblements qui se termineraient mal
où les gens se mettraient dessus et où
en plus on entend des à mort Israël ou
àt je ne sais quoi et bon voilà c je
pense que malheureusement il y a pas de
manifestation aujourd'hui qui soit
proalestinienne les manifestations qui
se mettent en place sont des
manifestations pro hamass on ne peut pas
manifester pour un groupe terroriste
est-ce que vous auriez accepté en
1900 38 39 à Paris ou à Berlin qui des
manifestations pro naaz
profascisme on ne peut pas accepter ça
et le Hamas est un groupe terroriste
d'une violence qu'on n pas connu depuis
très longtemps depuis daesh donc on ne
peut pas les accepter on ne peut pas les
interdire si un jour les choses s'appent
si un dialogue s'installe soyons voyons
l'utopie jusqu'au bout si un dialogue
s'installe entre Israël et et les pays
alentour les pays dont la Palestine
évidemment si un jour cela arrive oui
bien sûr quand il y aura des conflits
politique avec un langage mesuré et des
demandes qui soient logiques on pourra
organiser une manifestation
pro proalestine ou proisraélienne G etit
très respect
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec vous
parce que en en disant ça me rassure
mais en disant que les que les les gens
qui
manifestent ne peuvent pas manifester
pour la Palestine vous bridez vous
empêchez tous les musulmans modérés de
s'exprimer et dans ces manifestations
c'est pas vrai qu'il y a que des excit
jus B pas vous n'écoutez pas que j'ai
parfaitement écouté laiss les gens dire
on a le droit de soutenir la Palestine
des gens ont le droit de soutenir la
Palestine même aujourd'hui je suis pas
venu là pour disputer suis V h pour dire
quel chose parce que m'a invité j'avais
envie de parler de ce dont je veux
parler avez-vous eu dans les dernières
années ave vous vu une manifestation
prop palestinienne où on ne crie pas à
mort Israël mort aux Juifs mais quand on
crie
çaz avez-vous vu une PAL une
manifestation propalestin c'est vous qui
êtes un utopiste non parce que beaucoup
sont noyauté je suis d'accord avec
Valérie mais si vous laissez pas les
gens dire on soutient la Palestine vous
allez cristalliser totalement pas des
manifestations
proalestiniennes ce sont des
manifestations pro Hamas il ne faut pas
les accepter pas vrai bah si quand même
il y avait un drapeau iranien sur les
images qu'on voit DEP tout à l'heure
derrière cyil on a vu un drapeau iranien
et on a vu aussi des messages qui sont
vra toutes les personnes ont manifest
toutes les personnes qui ont manifesté
sont proterorisme non non c'est pas ça
qu'on dit on ve dire que c'est mal géré
mais moi je te dis je moi je suis pas
contre des
manifestations on peut pas AC
mais on peut pas accepter que sur la
stat de la République il a le drapeau
iranien bien d' mais
g g just veulent juste apporter un peu
de soutien oui mais faut le faire avec
le respect de
l'UR aller dans les de manif mais bien
évidemment ouis vraiment
ou moi s'il y avait une manifestation
logique palestinienne et logique
israëlien je ser aussi avec lui le
problème si vous voulez qu'on est on est
dans l'utopie là la situation est
brûlante on vientir un crime de masse un
un un génocide on vient on vient de
vivre quelque chose que qui est
insupportable qui est inhumain est-ce
qu'il y a des hommes qui peuvent faire
ce qu'on a vu faire est-ce que des
hommes peuvent s'appeler comme ça Primo
Levi a écrit un livre qui s'appelle si
c'est un homme au sortir des camps de
concentration il pourrait écrire le même
livre aujourd'hui donc on n'est pas dans
cette situation on n'est pas dans une
sit une situation d'apaisement où Force
Ouvrière fait une manifestation pour
réclamer une heure de de vacances en
plus ça n'a rien à voir avec ça on est
dans un état de guerre d'un monde qui
veut vivre à sa façon contre un monde de
terroristes merci Ellie d'avoir été avec
nous merci Ramous merci Ellie tout de
suite c'est le son de la viine
d'ailleurs sur C8 et lundi on traitera
l'affaire Marwan berini bien entendu
merci à tous